madame la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les membres du gouvernement
mesdames et messieurs les députés mes
chers collègues dans la nuit du 18 au 19
novembre à crépul dans la drô en pleine
fête de village est survenu un drame qui
endeuil et choque notre pays tout entier
plongeant chacun d'entre nous dans une
infinie
tristesse Thomas 16 ans a été poignardé
à
mort 16 autres personnes ont été
blessées à l'arme blanche dont trois
grièvement un déchaînement de violence a
fait basculer une commune française dans
l'horreur et je veux dire au nom de la
représentation nationale toute notre
solidarité de cœur et d'esprit devant
cette
tragédie je veux saluer la dignité et la
gravité de la Marche Blanche qui a salué
la mémoire de Thomas il imp te que
justice soit rendue et la justice n'est
ni la vengeance ni la vindicte pour
Thomas en signe de solidarité avec ses
parents sa famille ses amis ses proches
je vous demande mesdames et messieurs
les membres du gouvernement mesdames et
messieurs les députés de bien vouloir
observer une minute de
silence
je vous
remercie